hey doing i'm ryan right and i'm gerry
welcome the reasons to see we're gonna
give you some reasons to see maybe not
the [ __ ] see Don John let's go check
off reason to see number one Don John
Joseph gordon-levitt's acting fantastic
in this film quite enjoyed it a lot you
know what's great about this is everyone
knows that he like did everything on
this film including writing and
directing it it was awesome to see a
movie where it's like yeah going in a
new he wrote and directed it but I was
so engrossed in the character in the
performance I completely stopped being
aware that he was even behind the camera
at all he's really funny he's extremely
confident Joseph gordon-levitt just has
that swag that I can totally pull off
that level of confidence yeah I've never
seen him play quite such a Guido guy
like it like you're you know Jersey
Shore dude and and you know you kind of
do lose him into that character yeah
he's all about living up to a certain
image he's created for himself and you
know it's it's a total like macho image
that a lot of guys just try to live up
to you know work out body getting big
cheese on the side all the time you know
and of course porn for he's really good
with the porn addiction stuff in this
movie and I like at porn believe it or
not I have studied a lot on porn
addiction sex addiction there's a weird
fascination I've always had with it and
I I thought he did a great job with a
betrayal because this guy is a porn
addict who's in denial that he's a porn
addict it's so authentic in a certain
way but it's done in such a in a comical
way at the same time doesn't go to love
it just knew this guy in an hour huh in
and out I mean if she's maybe Joseph
gordon-levitt as a porn addict maybe
maybe that's what he was basing this off
with any he just loves porn yeah his own
real-life experiences reason is see
number two Scarlett Johansson I quite
enjoyed her in this movie a lot you know
I thought it was gonna be distracting
when I saw the trailer I thought it's
like oz gonna put on some phony accent
and whatever but but then I saw the
movie and I was I totally bought her as
this character buyer is a jersey
yeah it's she's very believable you
forget you're watching Scarlett
Johansson high maintenance you know kind
of control it will very controlling type
of person it's funny because it's like
just to go to love as a porn addict and
he's falling in love with someone who's
like a love addict a romantic attic in a
way you know but yeah they're very much
similar characters especially for the
first part of this movie you know it's
like they have their different
obsessions and their different images
that they're trying to embody but in the
end they are the same type of person
yeah it's it's another character that is
because this film's getting criticism
for its you know stereotypes but I think
that's the intention of this film is to
have stereotypes really played up to get
these points across because we all try
to sort of live up like the majority of
us try to live up to these certain
images of what a man should be like and
what a woman should be like it here's
what woman 1 here's what men want and
the clashes of that really feel
authentic in this film but in a funny
and entertaining way the whole time to
those are real things that people obsess
over in real life and try to live up to
because they think that's real and it
sort of prevents you from having those
authentic feelings you know when you're
dealing with people so they yeah I kind
of agree i think the stereotypes serve a
purpose in this movie you've seen these
types of people before and it's sort of
an exploration of who those people are
and what they become and i think the
main messages get communicated through
Don John and Scarlett Johansson's
character I'm very impressed with actors
who have to play like really confident
people to be happy so self-conscious and
doing something like that cuz he him for
josek gonna let me to pull this off you
have to be like super [ __ ] confident
when you do it every Scarlett
Johansson's character you got to be
super [ __ ] confident to pull off a
lot of these lines a lot of just a lot
of these scenes in general and damn do
they do a good job in the chemistry
between them they really play off each
other very well yeah they do definitely
reason to see number three Tony Danza at
Tony Tony he's back yeah role we wanted
him to be hit he didn't go so I don't
know I Murray had a talk show for a
while on that one nowhere yeah Tony
Danza I wasn't expecting to walk out of
this movie talking about Tony Danza but
I really enjoyed him in this film he
plays Joseph gordon-levitt's father and
the dynamics between father and son it
totally makes sense why don
ended up becoming Don John based office
not just his dad his parents he's so
funny in the hall too and he's
believable you know what I love about
the acting in this is he got strong
stereotypes but they're done with such a
level of sincerity and Tony Danza
totally brings that it's like you know
what Tony Danza it's gonna be totally
[ __ ] act I don't really know how to
elaborate on I just thought he was
really good yeah you know he's a small
character he's definitely a supporting
character damn is he is he like a
delight to watch every time he's on
screen I just haven't laughed so much at
a film in such a long time I laughed so
much at Tony did and tony danza you
never had a relapse much yeah recent
seen them before JGL is writing I
realize really impressed with the script
of this film you know because you're
dealing with a lot of tough subjects and
it's easy this moment I guess is a
dramedy if you're to categorize it yeah
it is a lot more comedy than your
typical dramedy in it that's what I
really appreciate about it was that it's
a dramedy that lives up to the Albany
Park you know a lot of drama DS are so
dramatic with very like a lot of just
black humor and I mean like yo what up
dawg I mean like dark humor it's true
that there's a lot of humor in there you
know from the types of characters these
people are like I said before it's kind
of like you're taking these Jersey Shore
type of guys and then making them human
what I just really appreciate bout is
that there's all these different
elements and they have to play with here
you know from like porn addiction to the
machoism to tell all these other
different things going on about it
basically is is anything that don jon is
going through that is what's being
communicated through feelings on the
screen is in a weird way it's like its
own world because it's kind of weird at
times it kind of funky well yeah you're
in his world yeah exactly this guy
occupies and part of what's so cool
about is writing to is that you know
it's like every character has a sort of
very distinctive quality about it you
know even though they're all New Jersey
folks you know they all have a
distinctiveness about them and also this
movie uses a lot of like internal
narrative I think he did it a good job
with that too because that's usually
something people scoff at but in this
movie it's you know the internal
narrative is very much based in the
character
in Don Jon's mind and so the internal
narrative isn't just sort of dictating
what's happening on screen it's also a
window into how he views things so it's
not always reliable to the truth but
it's reliable to his character and that
sort of changes that are going on reason
is seen number five JGL is directing the
direction of this is very neat because
like like what I was saying with the
writing is totally captured in the way
with the directing of how the the
feelings of what don jon is feeling
that's what you're gonna feel based off
the way how not just how it's written
but just how it's captured as well he
knows how to work with his editor pretty
damn well you know yeah it's definitely
got a visual style yeah and and it does
have a rhythm because a lot of the movie
revolves around this guy's routine and
so as they you know keep establishing
and keep using the routine there's lots
of creative a creative editing and
really cool shots and stuff like that
and it all sort of goes to serve what
this guy's life is you know yeah and I
liked how we use how we deal with all
the themes of everything you know like
with porn addiction for example um even
if you're not a porn addict everyone has
their own different opinions on it but I
really liked the dynamic of how it was
such a big problem for Scarlett
Johansson that her boyfriend is looking
at porn and when he's in a relationship
because I know that there are some
people who won't give a [ __ ] and some
people look down upon it in porn
addiction you know it's a real thing and
a lot of people disregard it is if not
being a real thing but do some research
will find out there's old it's a real
[ __ ] thing out there and with porn
addiction you usually get people people
get criticized a lot of time on their
character like other there's they're
selfish they have no self-control you
know there's womanizers and stuff and
the way how he captured it he managed to
make it such an entertaining fashion he
managed to capture a serious addiction
would such an enthusiasm and confidence
at the same time yeah definitely and
it's it's not in a way that's overly
cool but it's also not overly condemning
either it's just a fact of this guy's
life yeah he's actually he's not trying
to hit any points in your head you don't
he's not trying to bash anything in your
brain well it is it does match the idea
that this guy watches a lot of porn you
know that if I'm saying it's not trying
to bash like a message in your head yeah
yeah it's not taking a big preachy
stance ago
this is wrong let's watch porn you know
like like all the people are saying like
yeah it tries to be deeper than what it
really is but I think when people say
that I'm like no I I just don't think
it's as deep as you want it to be I
think it's just deep enough John is not
an incredibly deep guy to begin with and
the whole movie is sort of about
watching this shallow kind of you know
New Jersey robot guy turn into a real
person you know he's a guy who's going
is it guys like it's totally detached
from reality detach from his emotions in
so many ways you know it's like that's
why people like and get hooked on porn
because it gives them a certain feeling
that makes them feel you know feel in
general the shots are very composed and
it definitely has a succinct visual
style the editing is interesting even
the cinematography from even like
lighting standpoints there are cool
things they do with lights and stuff
like that you know it's as a directorial
effort you know good good first good
first one out of the gate it and he
knows how to cast very [ __ ] well why
he got all the right actors together
that everyone has there's a great rhythm
with the with a dialogue in this movie
reason to see number six Julianne Moore
can't really go into without ruining the
film she's an important character in
this film someone who starts off being
introduced as a small character but
eventually becomes you know the
characters were elaborated she does a
really good job in the film like that's
about as much as I can say yes yeah
she's really good she's very real and
you know there are some some definitely
impressive moments you know that she has
to really act in and again the chemistry
between her and Joseph gordon-levitt is
is really solid as ever you know with
two very different age ranges if they
play off each other incredibly well you
know look at it it's important that
point and I can't go into why but it's
it's important yeah they say that yeah
yeah no she's definitely very well cast
and she does a fantastic job redheads I
like redheads for in his room pornhub
com look up redheads there's a lot of a
wonderful pornhub gave them money i mean
i think so because on the porn hub
website i was on it before we did this
review and they have advertisements for
this movie your yarn yeah
find out him before every porn clip yeah
split decisions the last 30 minutes okay
I like the last 30 minutes but that is
where my few flaws come in i thought
it's even though it's only a 90-minute
film it's i thought it's sort of dragged
a little bit in the end cuz i kind of
wasn't sure what the direction of this
was really going I thought I got a
little too serious you know cuz it's
very comical for a lot of it there's
always a certain level of comedy and
then it got like very serious for the
last 30 minutes there was still some of
you where they got interjected but much
later on in the last 30 minutes yeah I
didn't necessarily take it that way
because I mean I didn't feel like it
vastly changed gears I thought the drama
took over a little more but the the
first hour of this movie is funny like
there's lots of humor that comes out of
these characters but it's not like a
comedy and then who drama like I thought
the shift made sense with the characters
and with the story and the tone wasn't
jarring at all you know I really like
the last 30 minutes and that's when the
biggest character chefs happen and and
that's what I was most compelled by so I
didn't even hardly notice I just thought
the first hour was just a ton of fun and
I felt that level of fun like
significantly did for me like i was
still intrigued I'm still interested
just the fun level was not there really
I think I guess is not supposed to be
the urban those moments I don't I just
didn't like the feeling of feeling my
energy just dropped then again I i watch
this movie this morning based on zero
hours of sleep so that might have to do
with it and I won't go into it but the
ending I kind of didn't like like like
the I like me it's weird I like the
ending but I didn't feel like it was
cook this story was finished and where
it ended I thought there was going to be
more after the last scene that we saw
and then it just sort of ended for me
and I was like I guess it's over and I
think quite get why it ended at that
point 10 feel like it's sort of it I
feel like it ended at the right point in
this character's life because to
continue any further beyond that it
would either have to be a very long film
or really rush wrap up because we ended
a point where he has become a different
person to continue on past that then we
would have to see his life as
that guy yeah I felt like this was like
a chapter one in Don Jon's life like
it's it's it's weird because this is not
the type of film that would get a seat
bull but I would if they made a sequel
to it like Don John chapter 2 or
something I would totally check it out
Ryan's consensus this might minor things
don jon is the reason movies are made
despite minor things don jon is the
reason movies are made yet I ok here's
my day I had literally no sleep I was up
all night catching up on breaking bad
and I was falling asleep during the
trailers and then this movie just really
uplifted me it picked me up it woke me
up here i am doing a review and you know
what it I love a movie that can just do
that in a unique fashion Sherry's
consensus a good debut in a very
enjoyable movie is the reason to see Don
John a good debut in a very enjoyable
movie the reasons to see Don John you
know I think it's a really solid debut
on all fronts for for Joseph
gordon-levitt behind the camera and I
really enjoyed it you know I thought it
was a you know well drawn movie and I
might actually go check it out again
love when I'm more sentient alright guys
thanks checking out a review for Don
John why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell us what is
your favorite Joseph gordon-levitt
performance and once you're done doing
that come over here and click this
button so you can see more of those
reasons to see because there's a bunch
of them there's a few things I like one
of the things i like is if you like us
on facebook another thing i like is if
you follow us on twitter you know what
else i like is uh people who want to get
updated every time new reviews of videos
out and for those people i recommend
that you subscribe subscribe doing
that's what we like and you're gonna do
it you know josek gonna love it he I
love keep you out like you got a very
neat haircut and jessica london has
unique hair in this movie too and I like
people who can pull off unique haircuts
like last week with the jake gyllenhaal
prisoners there you go yet it or johnny
depp and everything does yeah so yeah no
I I love his hair a lot at one point
Julianne Moore's comedy nazare and I was
thinking you know what I'm touches here
too I I like that and I also agreed with
the car
I was like yeah yeah it does look better
like that if you okay yeah Julianne
Moore she I don't know she's like 59 or
something but she is still gorgeous I
don't think you then yeah well yeah I
don't know 40s 50s what's the difference
she's a woman she's all know you just
B's agriculture 60 yeah yeah well you
know what's your past 40 in your what's
your past 40 you're 60 yeah that's how
it works when you're a woman you seldom
only 40th birthday than a year later
yourself reading your sixties birth mmm
mmm surprised you're not throwing on
this reaches